apaire l'interview superficie attention
est portée du verre au théâtre oui je
vais te mau corde dans un théâtre sur la
planète interdite en quand ça m'échappe
monde ont ramassé les trèfles à quatre
feuilles
quand j'ai le bonheur d'en trouver oui
de une patte de lapin chez vous un
sextoy sa patte de lapin bunny déjà
beaucoup de succès c'est une patte de
lapin car énorme et en plus on va lui
couper sa reprocher mais je me souviens
quand j'étais petit j'avais mis une
patte de lapin dans un sac et en fait
j'ai ouvert quinze jours à patrick au
sade revient maintenant que je rage n'a
pas laissé passer sous les échelles vos
wii ah ouais
facile et ça c'est clair les hommes sont
faites plus peureux touche du bois à
l'époque du genre pour conjurer le
mauvais sort ouais je touche du bois je
croise les doigts
ouais tu fais tout quoi quand j'ai très
hâte invite quelqu'un que tu viennes
quelques noms en tresse j'adore à 13
thèmes bien j'adore pour qui c'est un
bon chiffre
les chats noirs sapeurs des chats noirs
fois non j'ai pas peur de chagrin parce
qu'on en a tué beaucoup c'est comme les
chouettes effraies qui sont les oiseaux
magnifique conte épinglé sur les granges
faut protéger les chouettes effraies
pour mettre des nichoirs
voilà je vous dis à tout le monde ce
sera mon combat aux mains des nichoirs
et c'est ça que tu vas faire maintenant
bah je me verrais reconvertir dans la
défense des chouettes effraies on verra
moins pour les chouettes quand le pain
dans le mauvais sens vous le mettez de
l'autre côté non ah oui à la voile à 1
quand même tu jettes du sel comme ça toi
quand il tombe oui mais vous savez
pourquoi que ça porte malheur
non parce que le sel était une denrée
très rare et que si on renversait du sel
comme ça coûtait cher y avait un impôt
sur le sel alors les gens ils se
disputaient alors maintenant le sel on
le doit pas le passé si jamais il tombe
c'est une superstition qui vient comme
ça du moyen âge voilà il faut le poser
et on le passe c'est un simple con hein
mais ya plein de gens qui croient vous
savez vous quoi en chine présent non
mais pourquoi les ronds ont fait comme
ça ouais parce que les tipis frappé leur
machin pour que le vin ce mélange où la
bière comme ça il était sûr que l'autre
et la famille de poison pareil on se
serre la main pour montrer kaba d'armes
c'est exact je faisais part a pu à
l'intérieur toi non mais ça c'est parce
que je suis pas qu'on les a pas de fuite
john a trouvé le chemin
c'est michel lafon rien n'est sûr